merci la parole est à madame isabelle le
callennec j'y associe mes collègues
breton marc le fur
gilles lurton philippe le ray et thierry
benoit crise du porc viande bovine est
désormais crise du lait les éleveurs
n'en peuvent plus les tours de poterie
ministre de l'agriculture ne suffisent
plus
les éleveurs attendent des réponses
concrètes à leur détresse
le respect de l'accord sur les prix
avant avec la grande distribution
la promotion du produire français pour
manger français une stratégie de
modernisation des exploitations
agricoles
la baisse du coût du travail la fin de
l'avalanche réglementaire de la sueur
transposition européenne et des
distorsions de concurrence
toutes ces propositions sont sur la
table depuis des mois mais rien ou si
peu se passe comme si l'embargo russe ne
suffisait pas à leurs difficultés
s'ajoute désormais la crise grecque et
les incertitudes qui planent sur le
devenir de la zone euro la france est le
troisième fournisseur de produits
agricoles de la grèce est le premier
fournisseur de viande 650 millions
d'euros sont en jeu
à hauteur de 10 % pour les produits
agricoles et 90 % de produits
transformés à valeur ajoutée à ce jour
nombre d'abattoirs français se demandent
s'ils doivent continuer à alimenter
leurs clients grecs
la crainte est grande de ne pas être
payé en retour avec les conséquences
directes
là encore sur les éleveurs qui livre les
abattoirs
monsieur le premier ministre la maison
brûle et vous ne pouvez plus regarder
ailleurs le président du groupe l'est
républicain christian jacob vous a
demandé un plan d'urgence pour
l'agriculture
alors quelles initiatives comptez vous
prendre pour éteindre le feu
pendant un mois a pas dans six mois mais
a très très court terme
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur stéphane le foll ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt le président haddad la députée
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
choses en partie à la question laitière
je voudrais vous rappeler que sur cette
question
si aujourd'hui à une augmentation de la
production à l'échelle européenne
se tournant vers l'exportation vers les
particuliers s'y est à une décision qui
a été prise en 2008 de suppression des
quotas laitiers
à l'échelle européenne donc chacun doit
assumer sa responsabilité
il est très facile aujourd'hui dans
l'opposition de donner des leçons
je pourrais vous en donner sur d'autres
sujets ceci étant dit vous avez évoqué
les exportations vers la grèce
effectivement la difficulté de la grèce
aujourd'hui vous la connaissez ça sera
l'objet du débat de cet après midi c'est
l'objet des discussions qui sont engagés
c'est l'objet de l'engagement de la
france à maintenir la grèce dans la zone
euro sur cette question les opérateurs
que vous évoquez est un certain nombre
sont originaires de bretagne vous ont
peut-être sollicité mais nous ont déjà
sollicités et nous travaillons avec eux
pour faire en sorte que les garanties
soient données pour que les
exploitations puisse se poursuivre voilà
la réponse concrète et lorsque vous
parlez
madame la députée de la table ronde qui
a eu lieu où chacun a pris des
engagements et que vous dites que le
ministre ne fait pas suffisamment
je voudrais vous rappeler quand même que
si cette table ronde a eu un tête à
l'initiative du ministre
merci la parole est à madame viviane al